[Applause]
[Music]
the fear of uncertainty is called mana
phobia
I don't have that fear good morning have
a nice day
[Music]
what are you afraid of do sabiá the fear
of driving
what about acrophobia the fear of
heights
maybe it's an attribute the fear of
sharks the fear of jarring aquifer you
should have a phobia Nyctophobia
[Music]
or the fear of a blank page
they can't separate suburbia this is my
biggest fear
[Music]
truth is my morning wins something like
this and not that happy clappy living my
best life kind of ensured that I showed
you rather I burned my tongue on coffee
veneer on too scared to open up a pixel
book and see a blank page so I
daydreamed of the perfect morning and
stayed even though I have my favorite
creative overlooking me constantly sound
proving to make as much noise as
possible science to keep the peace voice
activation endless caffeine plants for
the indoor/outdoor feel itself hope
books and meditation the cursor never
stops blinking it's the fear of a blank
page Baek answer Papa Rosa phobia that
is my only driving force through
procrastination to complete every task
in the dying moments of its
to live life in the redzone
understanding that my career all rides
on this one piece of writing and if I
don't deliver it's over if my brain was
a volcano then my fear acts as this
vinegar to the bicarbonate of soda
that's inside here and then you have it
well an unsuccessful kids project that I
just spent the last four hours making
instead of writing my script and finally
after a walk I ran an ode [ __ ] black
art a camera workshop ass worm called
multiple phone call interruptions and
two food deliveries I am finally ready
to write
[Music]
John
I don't know why but this is the only
way that I can think creatively you may
call it procrastination but I call it
creative patients which is waiting for
the right moment to act I guess it's
like the method to my madness to kind of
wait for things to happen and when it
goes this way it's pretty remarkable the
kinds of ideas that spring to thoughts
I've started using this to ride my
scripts on thank you google for
forgiving this to me I'm not just
shamelessly plugging this thing
i-i'll gently use this to write my
scripts it's portable super light and
the battery life is really good I forgot
to add this there for my beard is a
little bit longer and and well I'm
wearing a different hat I just wanted to
add emphasis to how Fosters
like I really just take the whole Google
brand and I think that it embodies
really what we do here and connecting
people so thank you so much to Google
for bringing this video tonight it's
been rad exploring my creative patience
and other than that don't forget eurosam
brew and i'll see you next week
Wednesday
[Music]